okay welcome to the reason stream I'm
Zack Weiss Muller joined by my co-host
Liz wolf unless you've been in hiding or
under Iraq for the past several days you
probably know that Hamas launched a
brutal terrorist attack on Israeli
civilians last weekend Israel's
government has responded with a military
assault on Hamas and a total blockade of
the Gaza Strip to help us better
understand why Hamas would do this
knowing what the consequences were
likely to be for the people of Gaza and
where things are likely headed in this
war we've invited on Max Abrams a
political science professor at North at
nor Eastern University he studies
terrorists insurgents and Rebels and
understands better than most why they do
what they do and what the outcome of
their actions is likely to be um his
book rules for Rebels the science of
Victory and militant history lay his
theories out in detail and there's a
chapter devoted to his Time in the West
Bank during the so-called second inata
around 2001 where he studied Palestinian
terrorism and its consequences an
experience we'll talk about and which he
says led him to begin questioning some
of the conventional wisdom about
terrorism Max thank you for talking with
us thank you so much for having
me the attack
was shocking both because of the
atrocities Hamas perpetrated and filmed
and shared on social media for the world
to see and because of the reaction that
was sure to provoke why do you think
they did it in this way and at this
moment this really was shocking
everybody knows the Israeli palan
conflict has been full of political
violence and it goes back decades but
this was not business as usual this was
a truly unprecedented attack um the
numbers that I've seen being reported I
mean they're fluid and they keep going
up but I've seen numbers as high as
1,200 Israeli citizens being killed and
that is not only orders of magnitude
higher than any previous attack against
Israel but for any country um
th this will go down as to the best of
my knowledge the second biggest
terrorist attack um certainly against a
democracy um after 911 in terms of the
number of um citizens who were killed it
was also really not business asual it
was also a tremendous escalation in
terms of the number of perpetrators
there's a lot of talk in the west about
the so-called Lone Wolf and that makes
sense and one could be because in the
United States we don't have militant
groups running around like this um but
one could be left with the impression
that you know there's nothing more
dangerous than than the Lone Wolf
attacker um but you've probably heard
the expression there are power in
numbers um in general all else equal
when organization
grow in size numerically they tend to
gain capability and so there's a
correlation between the size of militant
groups and the number of perpetrators
they deploy and the amount of violence
they're able to inflict um we know based
on Israeli sources that um Israel I mean
I'm not talking about inside of Gaza but
outside so in terms of the number of
perss who came in from Gaza we're
talking about hundreds I mean I've seen
numbers like
1,500 um so that is also really shocking
um you might see something like that in
the context of a civil war um like in uh
Nigeria or something with bah Haram
where bah Haram goes into you know some
kind of a town with essentially like a
small army um but for it to happen
inside of Israel when although there was
this Baseline conflict which was ongoing
and simmering there wasn't you know open
you know hostilities and so for all of a
sudden in the course of a few hours
Israel to be flooded with let's just
call it500
perpetrators is extraordinarily unusual
not just for Israel but in the study of
terroris period um and so what we're
looking at is historical
escalation and everybody of course wants
to understand why why it's happening and
I think that there's a lot of confusion
and frankly I don't have 100% Clarity in
terms of what it is that Hamas is trying
to achieve if you look at universities
you know with these student groups um or
even you know in the media especially
more like left lean media you might be
under the impression that Hamas is in
favor of a two-state
solution that all it wants is a viable
Palestinian state that it's responding
to this right-wing Israeli government
that it's protesting against the rise in
Israeli settlement activity
in but that would be empirically
Incorrect and there are two reasons why
the first is if you actually look at
what the the terrorists claim to want
they say they're not in favor of a
two-state solution if you look at the
Hamas Charter they're in favor of the
destruction of Israel and so not only in
terms of what they actually say but in
terms of what they actually do there was
a time of course when the peace process
was going on and in the minds of many
people around the world including um the
Israeli public it looked promising in
terms of the creation of a viable
contiguous Palestinian State the basic
terms of it were it was a land for peace
deal where Israel would trade territory
in in exchange there would be a
cessation of Palestinian terrorism in
every single peace process every single
one um if you Google this Google Gaza
first it was always known that Gaza
would be independent first that they
would gain autonomy they would be the
first part um of the Palestinian
territory to become a state and it goes
back decades and although there's some
disputes about precisely how much land
Israel would seed in the West Bank you
know was it 95% was it 98% was it 93%
there's no and it really kind of depends
on interpretation as well as the fact
that there have actually been several
peace offers put
forward but there is no dispute
whatsoever that the future Palestinian
state would have been made up of the
vast majority of the West Bank and Hamas
was on the opposite side of this
itly opposed the peace process and acted
in a way to torpedo it by using violence
it acted as a so-called spoiler in order
to spoil negotiations which it did in
fact do and when you know shortly after
the signing on the White House law in
1993 you saw a uh you know an uptick in
Palestinian terrorist attacks and with
each one there was declining Israeli
support for negotiations and for a
two-state solution you fast forward to
um around 2000 which is when supposedly
the Oslo Accords were supposed to be
finalized resulting in a two-state
solution and by that point there was
very you know there was a lot less is
really public enthusiasm for negotiating
with the Palestinians and it's in that
context in which they built up this so
you know so-called security wall or
fence in the because it was seen as an
alternative to a two-state solution it
it was seen as a requirement for Israeli
Security in the absence of a credible
trustworthy negotiating partner and so
it's not true that the Palestinians want
a two-state solution and it's also not
true that historically Palestinian
terrorism has softened up the Israeli
public and made them more politically
conciliatory that it h that the
terrorism has undercut the political
right and empowered the political left
the exact opposite Benjamin Netanyahu
has thrived politically off of
Palestinian terrorism terrorism tends to
empower the hardliners the Israeli left
you could see it just disappearing with
each terrorist attack and so we're left
with the same question okay well then
what is it that Hamas wants if it's not
a two-state
solution
and one prominent
theory is that what terrorists want to
do is not
hoers governments into becoming more
politically
conciliatory but rather have the exact
opposite effect um that is to provoke
them and there's been a lot of research
in this area that goes back you know to
the 1970s David
frin uh David Lake wrote about it uh
more recently Tom Parker published a
book on this and the basic idea is that
what terrorists want to do is commit an
attack in order to get the government to
respond
forcefully and there's an understanding
that government responses to ter
terrorism are often indiscriminate that
they won't focus selectively on the
perpetrators but almost inevitably they
will harm the broader population and
when that happens members of the
population will become further
radicalized they will become perhaps
even more likely to join the ranks of
the terrorist group uh it might stir up
additional grievances it might
strengthen Revenge impulses and now this
might not seem strategic or beneficial
in the immediate term but imagine this
as a multiple iteration game where there
are multiple terrorist attacks there are
multiple times where the government is
overreacting and with each time the
ranks of the terrorists grow to the
point where now they're stronger and now
they're not perhaps seen as quite as
extreme
because local population are focusing on
the government reaction so if I'm
getting this correct your rough theory
that you're sort of sketching out is
that Hamas by attacking Israel and then
you know provoking the state and and
Israel then attacking in turn that this
makes you know arguably ordinary Gins
more likely to be sympathetic to the
Hamas cause is that sort of the rough am
I understanding your argument
correctly yes I think so it it is um
this is definitely a possibility um we
don't actually know exactly how popular
Hamas is in Gaza that's what I was going
to ask I was going to ask what evidence
do we have I I'm I'm open to this Theory
it's fascinating to me but what evidence
do we have that sort of lends Credence
to it if you could walk us through some
of that that would be really
helpful or so I don't want listeners
with the wrong idea I'm not suggesting
that Hamas is not currently popular in
Gaza it is it was elect in
2006 and there really haven't been
consistent you know to put it mildly um
open elections but by all indications
Hamas already is popular um and has been
popular since 2006 but these attacks
could even increase
hamas's popularity there are other
groups in Gaza which VI
organizationally against Hamas this
attack because Hamas is credited for it
and because Israel is so reviled you
know and detested among the Palestinian
population could um almost Elevate
hamas's status and this could happen not
only within Gaza but also in the West
Bank where historically Gaza I'm sorry
Hamas hasn't been quite as popular as it
is in Gaza the Palestinian Authority is
stronger in the West Bank and there
there are other groups um but I've
although most of the focus
understandably has been on Gaza I've H I
have seen you know imagery coming out of
the West Bank showing um you know
celebrations and enthusiasm
the level of enthusiasm and
supporters also extends beyond the
so-called Palestinian territories um it
could be that you know nasala uh joins
for in with Hezbollah could join forces
with Hamas um we've seen um big
celebrations in Aman Jordan um we've
even seen uh uh complimentary statements
that have come out of al-Qaeda
Affiliates and so Hamas could
essentially be positioning itself as a
leader in the larger Global Sunni um
terrorist movement and that would not
have happened without this unprecedented
attack against Israel and the inevitable
counter response which is seen as very
very unpopular um in countries
throughout the World frankly let me ask
you how this fits let's stipulate that
this is hamas's strategy or it's
objective how do I want to ask how that
fits into the framework that you lay out
in rules for Rebels uh you lay out some
of the rules here that I've highlighted
uh that a smart militant leader uh
recognizes that not all violence is
equal for achieving their stated
political goals the first thing smart
militants do is recognize that civilian
attacks are a recipe for political
failure so that you know the evidence
that you Marshall in the book for that
is that
when terrorists attack have some sort of
concrete political demand like we want
an independent state or we want more
land that typically when they attack
civilians the local population sorry my
camera went off but I'll keep talking uh
the local population turns against them
uh and they actually get less of what
they were asking for but in this case it
seems that you're
saying Hamas is not operating under the
assumption that they are going to get an
independent Gaza out of this but it's
more about you know positioning
themselves as the leaders of this you
know Sunni
jihadist
movement um do you think that
you know that will that be an effective
tactic uh or will it backfire do you
think it's likely to backfire in the
same ways that it has in these other
situations yeah so a lot of
people wonder whether terrorism quote
unquote
works right is Terrorism an effective
tactic for AG grieved groups
and there's no consensus on this
question and for a lot of reasons but
one of the reasons why is that it's not
entirely clear how one should measure
success so if the goal of a terrorist
group or an AG griev group is to
provoke a country into going absolutely
ballistic then terrorism is a very
effective um approach um part of that is
because there's at least some kind of an
implied social contract where the
government is tasked with defending the
population and so when it gets attacked
there's a lot of pressure to respond
also in Liberal democracies in
particular this there's an idea that the
individual matters greatly and that
civilians in particular are sacran that
they shouldn't be deliberately targeted
there's also just a lot of you know
Vengeance um that comes out of the
domestic population for a strong attack
and so I would say as a provocation
strategy terrorism is effective however
as an instrument coersion in terms of
pressuring governments into willingly
making concessions by appeasing the
perpetrators you know giving up the
demands that the perpetrators are are
asking for terrorism has a much worse
record um the I'm actually credited with
having published the first large end
study looking at the political
effectiveness of terrorism
and what I did was I took a sample um
from the state department of foreign
terrorist organizations every two years
uh the state department designates
groups and I actually
disaggregated the groups um in terms of
whether they mainly direct their
violence against civilian targets
violence against military targets and
the reason why I did that is because
although there there's no consensus over
the definition of terrorism most people
seem to understand that terrorism is an
anti-civilian
tactic and so when I disaggregated the
groups by their target selection what it
showed is that groups that primarily
direct their violence against civilians
that is by using terrorism have an
absolutely terrible rate of political
success in terms of the achievement of
their stated political goals whereas
groups that mainly direct their violence
against military targets have a much
better record at pressuring governments
to comply politically I'll just give a a
really brief example if you don't mind
um just to illustrate what I'm talking
about um take the example of uh
911 Osama Bin Laden was based out of
Afghanistan and the 911 11 attacks
happened and they of course primarily
struck civilian Targets in terms of the
World Trade Center
Tower um and so pretty much everybody
would agree any reasonable person would
agree that that was a terrorist
attack the United
States um you know rallied mobilized to
respond militarily it it was in it was
in no mood to begin
negotiating with um you know with
Al-Qaeda every lawmaker I think except
for Barbara Lee supported a a military
response right and the United and the
United Americans were all jazzed up
about going after um the al-Qaeda
leadership in
Afghanistan and then when we got there
the mission over time would sort of get
confused and morph from a strictly
counterterrorism operation to a
nation-building one the Taliban would be
tooed from the government and they would
actually assume the role uh of
terrorists or at least militants
insurgents and they directed their
violence against military
forces after a while as America you know
incurred the costs of that occupation
American support for it understandably
and predictably declined
before the United stat and so you know
the United States was essentially going
to do what the Taliban demanded by
getting out of their country before the
United States withdrew its forces it
said to the Taliban we don't want to be
here we don't want you attacking our
troops but you have to understand that
we could come back and we we we will
there's a good we'll be back if there's
another 911 like attack that that comes
out of Afghanistan that
targets you know the American population
spe you know specifically the civilians
and so I have a lot of large end data
but I'm also providing this empirical
example in order to um
suggest that there are variable effects
on target countries depending on their
target selection that governments tend
to behave differently when their
populations are attacked compared to
when their military is attacked and that
groups tend to have more success when
they isue civilian violence in that
sense they don't use terrorism and they
tend to use their violence more
selectively not as indiscriminately but
more selectively against government
forces and and against the military uh
and I think that the that the
Palestinians are um consistent with that
finding where we've seen as I suggested
that um when the pal when Palestinian um
groups used terrorism by attacking
civilians all it did essentially was
move the electorate to the political
right steal Israeli resolve and and
often lead to um very painful reprisals
against the perpetrators and often the
broader Palestinian
population and if you look at uh the
effect that you're saying Hamas wanted
to achieve with this which is to further
to to provoke a reaction that would
build a movement I want to look at what
is Israel's reaction has been it's an
it's an understandable reaction from the
government when a
brutal these these brutal crimes are
advertised uh and this is done in such a
you know just barbaric almost medieval
way um you know the the reaction from
Israel has been
to bomb the crap out of Gaza and to uh
basically engage in Siege Warfare uh we
have a clip from the defense minister of
Israel a couple days talking about that
strategy let's run that and then I've
got a question for you
about Israel's response
Max we are imposing a Complete Siege on
Gaza there will be no electricity no
food no water no fuel everything will be
closed we are fighting against human
animals and we are acting
accordingly th this is total war and
like I said on an emotional level I
understand why it's happening but if we
can try to talk on a strategic level for
a minute what do your studies of
terrorism and counterterrorism tell you
about this kind of overwhelming response
which is guaranteed to kill many
civilians yeah
so there of course is a is a field of
study called terrorism studies which
tends to look at nonstate actors like uh
it could be a wolf or a small group or a
larger organization that uses violence
against civilians for a political goal
um you most political scientists in the
west don't include government violence
um in the category of of uh
terrorism although it depends on one's
politics but it also depends on where
one lives geographically that's more
common to do for example out of the
Middle East Etc there is also a lot of
research separately on what's sometimes
known as civilian victimization and
civilian victimization is when
governments direct their violence um
against civilians and kill them in huge
numbers so there is research on that um
the most wellknown work is um by Alex DS
at GW or Benjamin Val
at Dartmouth um in
general um the finding the findings
which I find to be most credible are
that civilian targeting doesn't pay when
it's conducted by governments
either um and so essentially what I
found is that terrorism doesn't pay
where we Define terrorism as
nonstate um delber deliberately harming
the population and separately other
Scholars have found that when
governments essentially direct their
guns on the population that that too um
tends to be ineffective although there
does seem to be more of a empirical
dispute around that and one of the
reasons why perhaps nobody's tried to
really you know reconcile this but one
of the reasons why is because
governments have so much power National
militaries have so much power so it
could be that when the national
militaries are able to ramp up the level
of violence to a suff you know to a
sufficient level it might be well it
would be extraordinarily immoral but it
might be more you know more effective um
than say when non-state actors um harm
the population
so there is there is some good
literature on this and most of it would
suggest that that um any sort of
deliberately harm towards the population
um would not work to the benefit of the
government so would that be would that
imply then
that you know it's a obviously a tough
situation for Israel because Hamas
intentionally hides among the civilian
population Gaza but then they are but
but what I was goingon to say is they
are
um cutting off the water and power to
civilians and sort of sealing the exits
in terms of they they bombed the Border
Crossing into Israel into I mean I mean
into Egypt um that seems like a pretty
uh counter like based on what you're
saying that it would actually that would
be a pretty
counterproductive
response yeah just want to clarify
morality of it aside I I'm not
suggesting in any way that Israel is
deliberately harming the population um I
was really just trying to explain the
civilian victimization literature in
terms of what we know when the
government harms uh large numbers of
civilians in the population I honestly
believe that if it were possible for
Israel to kill every Lo terrorists in
Gaza without harming a hair on the head
of any um civilian in Gaza that it would
do so and it's just it is not
logistically possible because of the
tremendous population density within
Gaza as well as Zach what you were
describing which is that Hamas
intentionally by Design as part of its
strategy
in meshes itself in the population Hamas
literally puts its
headquarters beneath the the hospital
the main hospital in Gaza it shoots from
mosques and
schools its main strategy is to make it
impossible um logistically to separate
from the surrounding population and so
even if Israel tried its utmost just to
take out Hamas without harming a single
civilian um it would not be possible a
debate can be had about whether Israel
ears too much in terms of destroying
Hamas at the inevitable Mass suffering
that this will cause to the population
but it is a function of the difficult of
counterterrorism rather than any kind of
genocidal intent to harm civilians I
think what you're saying is very well
taken specifically the point which I
think many people don't know about um
about Hamas basically choosing to
operate in alifa hospital uh making it
uh so that they are legitimately covered
by the fact that if Israel actually
wanted to take out some of their um sort
of like the brains of their operations
they would have to do so by attacking a
hospital that is ministering to the the
injured uh but I do think there is this
question that we might be sidest
stepping and I would love to hear your
thoughts on this Max there's a blockade
uh and you know in like Gaza is dark now
uh they are using generators to power
ala hospital right now as we speak they
claim to have about two or three days of
fuel left last I read um once those
generators go dark I mean there's a huge
crisis where there's not any fuel left
left available to people in Gaza people
will not be able to perform surgery on
any of the Wounded um you know a lack of
clean drinking water food that was in
refrigerators that will no longer be
able to be consumed and and running out
of food Fuel and water this is a huge
source of suffering for you know two
million gazin and currently Egypt is in
no way playing any sort of role in
allowing people to cross via the Rafa
border crossing to the extent that that
is possible given Israel's actions or
any sort of humanitarian assistance to
allow safe passage of supplies to you
know the 43% of gaza's population that
is children what is the way for Israel
to do this I mean surely this blockade
are there any ways around this walk us
through that thought process as best you
can and give us your sense of is there
any way to minimize this amount of
Civilian suffering because we're seeing
staggering amounts of suffering in Gaza
right
now well first of all Zack and Liz I'm
very impressed you know with with all
the with all the research that you've
done both on the conflict and in terms
of my own work um you really have this
covered here I mean I do not no I don't
know the answer to that I don't know how
to crush
hos and not harm the population I mean
there is the rub um it is you know I
myself am a father I have a you know a
child like there there's a huge youth
population in
Gaza and no matter what your
politics you know a child a baby they
have nothing to do with this conflict
and they don't deserve any suffering
from it and the utmost should be done to
to spare them and to have them
Prosper um perhaps there some progress
could be made on the Egyptian border as
you're
suggesting um Egypt has a a long history
with Gaza Egypt used to occupy Gaza a
lot of people seem to forget that from
1949 to
1967 we've been told as well that it was
Egyptian intelligence which appears to
have actually been better than Israeli
intelligence in terms of the October 7th
attack um so Egypt is no stranger to
Gaza and it remains to be seen what the
CC government will do about this I would
like to see um a corridor opened up um
to help the civilians I mean even if I
mean I haven't really thought about this
solution in detail there are you know
human rights workers in the region who
probably have more concrete ideas than I
do but maybe there could be a quarter
that would opened up we opened up below
a certain age everybody gets out without
questions um uh I don't understand why
food wouldn't be allowed to be brought
in um sure on the mar you know you could
make it confusing if you want to suggest
like dual use technologies that could be
civilian and Military but even leaving
those aside surely there could be
humanitarian assistance which would
provide really no military value
offensively whatsoever other than
sustaining the
population um so I would love to see as
much humanitarian progress as possible
um I do know I mean I've seen reports
that some of the attackers were actually
the workers were actually I was about to
ask you what you make of that because I
know Israel has been generous with
extending work permits to Gins which is
a component to this that I think many
critics of Israel don't pay very much
attention to uh and are a little
reticent to talk about but the fact of
the matter is that that border is
somewhat permeable to Gins who are
interested in working I think
specifically the construction industry
uh in Israel is is pretty populated by
Gins what do you make of this Theory
that's been circulating that this is one
of the means by which Hamas was able to
infiltrate Israel and catch them off
guard it's horrible I mean in in the
even not looking at this case but in
previous cases where the
perpetrators were not
necessarily um
workers right there might have just been
an attack could have even been a rocket
attack a common Israeli response has
been to seal off the borders even more
to to reduce maybe even you know suspend
uh worker permits and if it's true you
know that the actual perpetrators were
the ones being allowed back and forth
into Israel then that only sort of
reinforces the Strategic logic of of
sealing off the border to the detriment
to the further detriment
of the gazen um population but it is
another
example um of how terrorism often
backfires on the perpetrators assuming
the perpetrators care at all about the
population they claim to
represent I wanted to ask you about
another aspect of your work or another
finding that I F that I came across in
your book um I'm just trying to add it
to this there we go
um you mentioned at one point that many
scholars expect violence whenever
mass-based movements of nonviolent
reform are politically
unprofitable and this is the exact line
of argumentation that you hear from the
Palestinian side is that for many years
we've tried
to have a mass movement to to get some
politic rights uh that has been denied
and rather than have me lay out their
argument I've pulled uh a clip from um a
gentleman uh that who's on fared Zakaria
show from uh he's the head of one of the
major uh his name is Mustafa baruti he's
the leader of the Palestinian national
initiative which is a political party in
Palestine that's not affiliated with
Hamas it's not part of the PLO either um
and he I think lays out the Palestinian
point of view succinctly I'd like to
just play that and get you to respond to
what he lays out there let's roll that
clip has evolved is a direct result of
the continuation of the longest
occupation in modern history Israeli
occupation of Palestinian land since uh
1967 this is 56 years of occupation that
has transformed into a system of aparti
a much worse aperti than what prevailed
in South Africa uh yes maybe Hamas did
not recognize Israel but the PLO did and
the Palestinian Authority did what did
they get nothing since 2014 the Israeli
governments would not even meet with
Palestinians and what you see today is a
reaction to several things first of all
settlers terrorist attacks on
Palestinians in the West Bank that has
eved or already 20 communities in an act
of ethnic cleansing 248 Palestinians who
were killed by the Israeli Army and
settlers in the West Bank including 40
children attacks on the holy sites the
Muslim and Christian holy sites by
Israeli
extremists as well as Declaration of
Netanyahu that he will liquidate the
Palestinian rights and the Palestinian
cause by normalization with Arab
countries and he dared even to go to the
United Nations and carried in the United
Nations a map of Israel which included
the whole of the West Bank all of Gaza
all of Jerusalem as well as the Golan
Heights he declared the annexation of
the occupied territories so of course
Palestinians turn to resistance because
they see that this is the only way for
them to get their rights the question
here is not about dehumanizing
Palestinians as is happening and calling
them terrorists it's about asking the
question why the United States supports
Ukraine in fighting what they call
occupation while here they are
supporting the occupier who continues to
occupy
us what do you think of his assertion
that Palestinians have been backed into
a corner specifically by the Netanyahu
administrations kind of aggressive
expansion plans the expansion of
settlements and they're now in its
corner with no good options occupied by
the you know amidst an occupying
Force yeah I think it's important for me
to say and for people to understand that
although the conflict is often you know
called the Israeli Palestinian conflict
that there are huge
differences um within the Palestinians
and and also within the Israeli side in
terms of their political views in terms
of their tactical
approaches I don't mean to suggest at
all that the Palestinians are
categorically
rejectionist of a two-state
solution I believe that there are many
many
Palestinians who if they could snap
their fingers they would would easily
trade um Israeli territory withdrawals
to UN resolution 242 borders and they
would you know not support violence and
in most cases maybe never supported
violence even in the first place um so
that that gentleman you know
barouti um sounds like he's not
rejectionist and that he his
main
demand is for there to be a two-state
solution which does have some residents
among Israelis on the left does it
resonate with the current Israeli
government no the the current Israeli
government is not in favor of a
two-state
solution um it seems that they would
like to take over completely the West
Bank and so this government under
Netanyahu and the way that he has formed
it by moving to the right it's
impossible to imagine them being the
ones to be party to any um political
resolution to this conflict so yeah I'm
not sure that I disagree all that much
with some of what that speaker on fared
Zakaria said
you know uh you mentioned earlier that
Hamas has been they were this kind of
spoiler because there were
constituencies on both sides for a
two-state solution and Hamas obviously
did not want that because they don't
think Israel should exist uh and but
then you know I've read reports uh that
have said that some of the right
right-wing factions in is real kind of
boosted Hamas over the years there's
been intelligence officials now that
have gone on the record and say like we
made a mistake by boosting Hamas when we
should have dealt with the PLO um how
much you know how much truth is there to
that Dynamic does that exist that these
two sides have kind of been feeding on
each other over the
years I'm sure there is a symbiotic
relationship between the Israeli right
and um you know the more radical groups
within the Palestinian political May uh
it might even be strategic um I mean in
some sort of cynical way um because you
know if you really don't because I never
said Netanyahu wants a two-state
solution you know let's assume that he
doesn't um then why not build up um your
adversary uh who's also not in favor of
a two-state solution that would probably
um lower the likelihood of a two-state
solution being put on either of them um
it's not uncommon for a government to
support a group and for things to kind
of get out of control um in terms of
there being backlash I mean we the most
famous case is the mujahedin which you
know the US supported and over time that
would morph into the early of al-Qaeda
um I would argue although some chks
would disagree with me that that erdan
um also um
facilitated deliberately the creation of
the caliphate by having a very porous
border with Syria and allowing tens of
thousands of foreign fighters to cross
over and then um sometimes um Isis has
actually attacked inside of turkey and
so when I've said you know when I've
accused the erdogan government of being
State sponsors of terrorism Turks will
say how could you possibly say that
turkey has been a victim of Isis
terrorism and turkey has also used its
military on various occasions to fight
against Isis and the truth is all of it
is true it is true that they helped Isis
and it is true that they suffered at the
hands of
Isis is wanted to you want to bring up
some of the audience questions and then
after that I would like to talk a little
bit about the role that the US has
played and will play in all of this well
the the comment that most uh stuck out
to me was by Jesse JB uh which said I
guess in response to what I had said
related to work permits for Gins
generous what a messed up thing to say
given the circumstance I I think this
really um you actually go back to the
sentence because that comment just means
absolutely nothing Jus let's let's back
up to the sentence I had characterized
uh you know the uh practice by the
Israeli state of issuing work permits as
a sort of Lifeline to Gins as a generous
thing to do especially in the context
something
that they disagree with something you
said yeah exactly uh and I just wanted
to respond to that and really
communicate I mean this is all in the
context of possibly it being through
that system that Hamas infiltrated
Israel and gathered more intelligence to
be able to carry out this attack so it
came at Great risk to the Israeli State
and then I think it's also worth
considering I mean by the numbers I
think it's something like 15,000 to
20,000 work permits that are issued by
Israel uh to gsin to work in
Agricultural and construction sectors
primarily and then I believe we have
about 100,000 work permits issued to
those in the West Bank to be able to
work in Israel from what I have read and
I know the Associated Press does some
pretty good reporting on this you know
you're you're expected to make about 10
times as much in Israel than if you
attempt to find a similar job in the
same sector in Gaza I'm sorry but we
have a 50% unemployment rate in
Palestine and just crippling poverty
refugee camp like conditions um I am not
in any way characterizing Israel's
overall role toward Gaza as generous
since they are obviously leveling entire
neighborhoods entire apartment buildings
uh and you know killing I think the
death toll is up to over you know 1,200
now with 6,000 people injured um and
likely to be updated even more I'm not
characterizing the actions of Israel on
the whole toward Gaza as generous but I
am saying that specifically with the
issuance of work permits to me this
looks like something the Israeli
government does at pretty substantial
risk to them in an effort to ensure that
civilians don't have to live in total
poverty and squalor under the thumb of
Hamas uh you know they obviously do have
to deal with Hamas because that is what
they elected and there are all kinds of
ways that that continues to affect their
daily life but to me at least the
issuance of work permits to attempt to
give regular ordinary people as best
they can tell a little bit of a Lifeline
to a better life is not in anyway a bad
thing and that is a very generous thing
uh that more governments should probably
do though I think it's important to be
very cleare eyed about the the risk that
that poses so I wanted to clarify and
sort of communicate to uh the comments
along those lines that I fully 100%
stand by what I said let me pull up one
more comment here that I think Max might
be able to address because it goes to a
question that we have faced here often
in the US if you go to war against a
country with no military how do you know
when it's over so in other words if
you're fighting against a sort of you
know a a militant group like Hamas that
and if this start you know spreads into
a more widespread jihadist movement
along the lines of
Isis when is it
over honestly I don't think it will be
over I think that um there there's no
foreseeable end point to any of this um
I mean
Hamas is popular and it
terrorism doesn't
require that much to do you know you
could have a gun you could set something
on fire you could fly a kite it it you
know it you with relatively just minimal
tools you can terrorize people um and
even if Israel were to completely atract
Hamas
militarily which seems
unlikely there will be successors and
there will be angry people who want
revenge and of course they will pick up
arms as well um so I think I actually do
agree with the Israeli goal of trying to
destroy Hamas as a terrorist group in
terms of its ability to mount operations
against is isra civilians I understand
that goal I think that that would be the
goal of any government that had faced a
similar you know a commensurate
terrorist
situation um but no matter how
successful they are they will fall short
I
suspect um and as we've mentioned the
cost to the Palestinian population is
going to be
horrific let's turn to us politics
because obviously we've had a more than
two decades war on terror um and a
there's a special relationship between
the US and Israel and America sent giant
aircraft carriers to the
Mediterranean many of The Usual Suspects
have been rattling Sabers against Iran
uh there's been a lot of speculation
about Iran's involvement that is
still not nailed down but suffice it to
say the level that you know even though
that's undetermined at this moment it
has not stopped the beat of the the war
drums within the GOP uh so I want to
roll a montage of Nikki Haley Mike Pence
and Lindsey Graham talking about the
current situation in
Iran
President Joe Biden's cow Towing for the
last two and a half years to the mulles
in Iran lifting sanctions begging them
to get back in the Iran nuclear deal and
then uh paying $6 billion dollar in a
ransom uh for hostages I think set the
conditions for this unprecedented
terrorist attack by Hamas against Israel
but I also believe this is what happens
when we have leading voices like Donald
Trump VC Ram Swami and Ronda
signaling Retreat from America's role as
leader of the Free World when they took
these hostages when they murdered these
families they were celebrating and what
were they celebrating they were saying
death to Israel death to America this is
not just an attack on Israel this is an
attack on America because they hate us
just as much for every Israeli or
American hostage executed uh by Hamas we
should uh take down an Iranian oil
refinery the only way you're going to
keep this war from escalating is to hold
Iran
accountable so look
um Israel has a self-interest to respond
to this with great force for Nikki Haley
though to say that an attack on Israel
is an attack on
America that is you know it's an attack
on Israel and that that should be bad
enough um and to immediately start
conflating those interests and then for
Lindsey Graham
to you know we have an interest in
getting us hostages back but to start
saying we should be bombing Iran's uh
oil refineries and just ratchet it up to
level 10 immediately Am I Wrong to view
this as really alarming
rhetoric I think that you're right to be
worried especially given the war on
terrorism and how voices just like these
led us so far astray and it was I don't
need to repeat to your audience but
going into Iraq was not just a
humanitarian disaster for the Iraqis but
strategically idiotic for the United
States in terms of its counterterrorism
goals by taking out Saddam and enabling
you know alqaeda and Iraq to to really
flare up and over the years to to morph
into Isis um we need to be really
careful about um American missteps at a
time when you know in the immediate
aftermath of a terrorist um
tragedy um I also think that the media
has an important role to play in this
and even before we start talking about
policy prescription you know what should
the US response be we need to understand
what exactly
happened right I mean with 911 there was
a lot of false talk or lies about the
role of Iraq um even before we start
thinking about what the you know
response should be if any to Iran we do
require
more clarity into precisely what Iran's
role was and I think that the media can
do a really good job of explaining to
Citizens what it is that we actually do
know and what our confidence level is in
the things that we say so for example
what we do know and this is again this
precedes discussion about what the
American policy response if any should
be it's just as a basic factual matter
here you know what we do know for sure
is that Iran is a state sponsor of
terrorism if you of course def uh
include Hezbollah and Hamas as terrorist
groups not everybody does but the state
department does and most academics do
certainly political scientists in North
America we we know that there's a
there's a level of Iranian support of
these groups they're not the same for
Hezbollah they have an even stronger
connection to Iran than Hamas does
Hezbollah was there at the very origin
of Hezbollah whereas Hamas is more of a
autonomous group that um I believe
essentially could have formed even
without um that even without Iranian
backing um it's not hard to imagine
so you don't need Iran to explain Hamas
in the same way that you need Iran to
explain heah which was part of exporting
the Iranian Revolution Etc um so we know
that there's a certain level of Baseline
Iranian support of these groups to
various extent um there was a report
which we're kind of talking around which
came out of the Wall Street Journal
which suggests uh a much higher level of
direct Iranian
involvement um that they uh not only
were aware of the um operation but they
greenlighted it and it goes to the very
top of uh Iran and um these um terrorist
groups um some people if I could just
for just a second let me just read a
couple excerpts from that article you
referenced um Iran you know the the
headline uh which our viewers can see
but I'll read for our listeners Iran
helped plot attack on Israel Over
several weeks uh this was uh this came
out on October 8th uh Iranian security
officials helped plan hamas's Saturday
surprise attack according to senior
members of Hamas and
Hezbollah um us officials say they
haven't seen evidence of Tan's
involvement Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin said we have not seen yet seen
evidence that Iran directed or was
behind this particular attack but there
was certainly a long relationship there
was some subsequent reporting from
Newsweek which talked directly to some
Hamas Fighters or leadership uh they
said the Iranian or sorry it was the
Iranian mission to the United Nations
who they talked to told Newsweek that
Iran did not have a direct hand they say
we've supported Palestinian fighters in
acquiring fishing skills they independ
determine when where and how to engage
in fishing according to their very own
needs and interests so I mean to to your
point we just need to tread carefully
here and understand that all parties
involved are going to have incentives to
spin this one way or another and um
until things are I think we we've
learned from very recent history that we
need real confirmation before kind of
jump taking the next step
forward this is an extraordinarily
weighty
allegation and the more consequential
the
allegation um the more important it is
to to get the basic facts right um I've
heard people say things like well look
at the sophistication of the attack like
that's like so facto you know evidence
that it must have been there must be um
Iranian involvement I mean I think
that's some of the strong evidence is
that a Hamas leader um said I believe
that there was Iranian involvement but
honestly I I I was doing this same sort
of work um in
2003 and I was duped um about all sorts
of allegations about Iraq and and I said
that I would never do that again that
that that for me the evidence would have
to be higher for other people they may
have seen enough um
so um but I do think that there's an
important role in the media of
clarifying what it is that we do know
and and don't at this point I do that if
a second front is opened up in terms of
Hezbollah um we could assume that that
second front does have the blessing of
Iran I don't believe that Hezbollah
would open up a second front um without
um Iran greenlighting it because they've
been so involved in all aspects of
Hezbollah but again historically the
same has not been true about Hamas I
also want to just make it very clear
that that I'm not ruling out the
possibility that Iran was involved in
this attack that that it did help Hamas
more than its traditional Baseline
levels um I'm just saying that I would
like to even to see even more evidence
along those lines drawing the
conclusion one thing that I'm curious
about is you are saying if Hezbollah
opens up a northern front um you know
then then we have a little bit more
evidence uh to substantiate this idea of
Iran being
involved with the fighting that's
currently going on on the Northern front
do you sort of characterize that as like
not quite you know it's more sort of
routine something that happens fairly
frequently where the Iron Dome
intercepts some amount of Hezbollah
activity but that that just sort of
hasn't um gotten to the point where we
really consider that to be a northern
front opened up or how do you look at
that because there have been some
reports of activity there no no no I I I
would say a northern front has not been
opened up um in in close to Israel's
border to the north of it there there
there are other militant groups and they
sometimes um you know commit attacks and
there might even be some Hezbollah
members um who commit some small attacks
um it's basically a communication
strategy among these agreed groups and
Israel Israel will respond um sometimes
in a proportional way it it's basically
a way for them to talk to each other um
through violence but when I'm talking
about when I'm talking about opening up
a second front there will be no doubt
I'm talking about taking advantage of
tens of thousands of these Rockets um
really uh negatively acting um you know
large numbers of Israeli civilians uh if
nasrala really opens up and basically
doesn't hold his military power in in
reserve a in authorization like that by
Nala I believe would require um Iranian
consent that makes sense the parallel
that I would draw because I know a
little bit less about the part of the
world that we are talking about right
now but I do know a fair bit about China
and Taiwan is you know we see a lot of
news reports when Chinese jets fly into
the taiwan's air defense identification
Zone um and so frequently there are
these very sensationalist sort of
breathless reports of like oh my God is
China invading Taiwan is this finally it
and in fact some number of um you know
airospace encroachment is actually
pretty routine uh it's not to say that
Taiwan welcomes that or enjoys it but it
is just to say that for people un for
the uninitiated who don't follow uh
Chinese Taiwanese relations very closely
that can look very alarming but in fact
is actually a somewhat routine thing so
it seems like you're drawing that
careful Distinction on the Northern
front too I just wanted to make that
clarification the other thing is that
when we're dealing with militant groups
um a common um you know thing to happen
is that there could be some sort of a
principal agent problem where uh you
know lower level members like you know
low-level operatives could act in ways
that don't necessarily have the blessing
um of the principal of the leader you
know um so what we're looking at what
we've seen so far is basically
relatively small amounts of violence but
I'm talking about the amounts of
violence which would require um nasala
to essentially declare war um on Israel
that would involve Iran more so but then
the next question everybody wants to
know of course is just moving this along
is what should the US you know response
be
um how involved could it get directly
right yeah and you know to that question
you know as you know you're talking to a
largely libertarian audience and on
libertarian social media this week
There's Been various clips of Ron Paul
circulating around and I wanted to play
one of those to open up that
conversation about what the US role in
Israel and Palestine has been and should
be moving forward so let's roll that
clip of Ron Paul from 2001 voting
against a um uh a sort of re uh voting
against a resolution that would have
condemned uh a Palestinian bombing of
Israel at the time uh and he was the
sole Republican to vote against that and
this was the speech he gave in support
of his vote so let's roll
that we here today talk about being
having solidarity with Israel
and others get up and and try in their
best way to defend the Palestinians and
and the Arabs so it's sort of a contest
should we be pro-israel or pro-arab or
anti-israel or anti-arab and how do we
how are we seen and doing this and it's
pretty important but I think there's a
third option to this that we so often
forget about why why can't we be
pro-american what is in the best
interest of the United States we haven't
even heard that yet I believe that it's
in the best interest of the United
States States not to get into a fight a
fight that we don't have the wisdom to
figure out now I would like to have
neutrality that's been the tradition uh
for America at least a century ago to be
friends with everybody trade with
everybody and to be neutral unless
somebody declares war against us but not
not to demand that we pick sides now I
have a proposal and a suggestion which I
think fits the American tradition that
we should treat both sides
equally but in a different way today we
treat both sides equally by giving both
sides money and telling them what to do
not a million dollars here or there not
a hundred million here or there but tens
of billions of dollars over decades
always trying to buy peace and my
argument is that it generally doesn't
work that there are unintended
consequences these things backfire they
come back to haunt us so I think we
should start off by defunding defunding
both sides I I'm just not for giving all
this money because every time there are
civilians
killed on the Israeli side or civilian
killed on the Palestinian side you can
be assured that either our money was
used directly or indirectly to do that
killing so we are in a way an accomplice
on all this because we fund both sides
the policy of foreign
non-intervention where the United States
is not the bully it doesn't come in and
tell everybody exactly what to do and
put these demands on if we didn't do
that yes we could we could have some
moral authority to come condemn violence
but should we not condemn violence
equally could it be true that only
innocent civilians have died on one side
and not the other other I don't believe
that to be true I believe that it
happens on both sides and on both sides
they use our money to do this I urge a
no vote on this
resolution what do you think of Ron
Paul's idea that America would be better
off and actually so would Israel and
Palestine if the US just cut off Aid Al
together uh to both
sides what I would say is probably not
directly answer that but I would say
that so
far I think that the Biden
response has been good I think that the
attack was just
appalling and I think that the
administration unlike honestly a lot of
people around the world have
recognized how horrible the violence
was the United States to the best of my
understanding has told Israel that it
will support it with the Iron Dome that
it that basically you need to replenish
the stocks and it's very expensive
because its adversaries have so many of
these these rockets and that the United
States will provide assistance which is
defensive assistance in that area and
that I also support I was surprised to
see this but such a swift a swift
dispatch um to the Eastern Mediterranean
as a deterrent again I think that that's
strategic and although the Pauls might
disagree and think that that's too much
American involvement um it comes at very
low cost for the United States and could
actually save money and prevent future
incentives which could increase the risk
of embroiling the United States more um
in a wider Middle East conflict so in my
mind those are the three main responses
of the Biden Administration it's been
rhetorical it's been for defensive um
Weaponry especially with the Iron Dome
and then also moving the ship closer to
um Hezbollah uh to warn Hezbollah and
Iran and I believe that us diplomats
have been in touch um with both of those
International actors telling them
warning them that the United States
could um get involved so thus far from
what I've seen um I have uh approval and
I'm not sure that um the Biden
administration's response has
necessarily rankled um those who are
sympathetic to a more libertarian
approach to foreign policy yeah what
about this that what about this point
that um that sort of pouring money into
the region over the years H with under
this pretense that you know it's G to
get in the right hands and it's going to
be used in a way that advances us
interests in the region that it just
hasn't worked out that way um you know
there's been since its Inception about a
quarter of a trillion dollars gone into
Israel several tens of billions to
Palestine about half a billion to
Palestine since uh the Biden
Administration took power and you know
we don't know how that money has been
used presumably at least some of it has
been used to obtain Rockets or weapon
other weapons to go into Israel um I
mean
I know we're in the midst of a fight
right now that it's it's hard to it
might be hard to think about these
questions but going forward is that
something that needs to be rethought the
amount of Aid that's the US Aid and
weapons going into the
region I mean I want to provide a little
bit of context here and that is when it
came to the origins of you know Israeli
State and Us levels of support for
Israel the US ended up
supporting um Israel not for strategic
reasons for humanitarian reasons in the
aftermath of the Holocaust as well as
domestic political reasons because of
course you know some prominent American
Jews were very much in favor of Truman
recognizing Israel us support for Israel
stayed relatively low until after the
Six Day War it wasn't immediate but
after that there was the so-called War
of Attrition around
1970 and at that point really shown in
The Six Day War but it took a little
couple years you can see a major major
uptick and US military support for
Israel and all of a sudden Israel was
seen as
um not just worthy of support for
domestic reasons or humanitarian reasons
but as a strategic Ally in the context
of the Cold War and Israel did Israel
was useful strategically to the United
States in the Cold War as the main us
proxy in the Middle East you know the
Soviets had them on their side and and
the US had Israel on its side when the
Cold War
ended the Case for
Israel um became harder to make
for for for groups like APAC because
they had been used to selling Israel as
a strategic asset in the context of the
Cold War and then what made it even
tougher was you know a decade little
more than a decade after the Cold War
ended you had the the 911 attacks
where Osama Bin Laden you know listed a
whole lot of reasons for why he attacked
us but one of them um was essentially uh
us relations um with Israel and so
increasingly it seemed that American
citizens were wondering well you know
what do we get out of this deal not only
is Israel no longer a strategic asset
but it might even be a liability
the one of the reasons why I think that
the US has had such a strong
relationship with Israel beyond the
typical causal
explanations you know domestic American
Support um uh sympathy shared values Etc
all that is something really simple and
that is that in general Israel has
shared very similar enemies as the
United States and so when the When when
when when when DC thinks of who its
enemies are they're often really similar
to the enemies which are shared um in in
Jerusalem and we see that working with
respect to us relations with Saudi
Arabia you the you know terrible
relations um with Iran um and I think
that there's a lot of sort of emotional
value which translates into support at
least at the policy level um by having a
lot of the same Mutual enemies and and a
lot of the enemies actually make it easy
because they'll actually say death to
Israel death to America and it creates a
a very sort of easy opening for people
like Lindsey Graham to say not only do
we have shared enemies but we therefore
have you know shared interests in that
essential like Nikki Haley might suggest
an attack on Israel is is you know is an
attack on America um but I just wanted
to provide a little bit of context to
listeners in terms of how we got to this
point in terms of the trajectory of us
support for Israel yeah that's that's
super useful um context uh I did want to
turn uh everybody's attention to a few
comments that we've gotten there are
actually some really interesting
questions and I think you can speak to
some of these uh Max one of of them is
from Lial and um it says reason TV why
is Gaza entirely dependent on Israel for
its day-to-day existence I.E water fuel
electricity could you explain and give a
little bit more context to the 16-year
blockade um I think this is something
that is frequently sort of misunderstood
about relations between Gaza and
Israel well I do think that Gaza gets
more support um than that question would
suggest um it gets um international
support from
uh you know allies in different
countries I think turkey is actually
currently sending over some support
cutar the
UN Supply support um the US even to an
extent um as Zach was suggesting uh
provides a certain measure of support um
and as you suggested this Israel also
Egypt um but uh I would like to see um
again I I I I I want to hold out this
belief it might be naive but I do want
to hold out this belief that it is
possible to have a punishing response to
Hamas which it earned at the lowest
possible cost to the
population and anything that could be
done to um Safeguard the population
during this counterterrorism response
should be done and I'm quite sure more
could be done along those lines well the
thing I'm curious about though and I I
wonder whether this listener is getting
at that is isn't this crazy that Hamas
was elected um I guess you know at this
point quite a while ago and yet
conditions haven't improved really for
civilians in Gaza and they are still so
reliant on Israel for so much um you
know could you do you have any can you
speak to the conditions sort of on on
the ground there uh the fact that
they're not in any way sort of like self
sustaining or self-reliant and the fact
that Hamas sort of neglects uh its own
people is pretty
disturbing yeah I mean these are really
good questions but I honestly don't have
any you know a whole lot of color to
provide um that the that this population
is really suffering and it is dependent
on uh essentially foreign assistance and
contributions and yet the quality of
life is absolutely terrible I mean what
research shows is that in
general terrorism tends to backfire um
and that's one of one of the really sad
aspects of this is that and why one
really can't be optimistic is because
the leading party in Gaza although it
has popularity is actually doing the
Gins a disservice now when I say that I
don't mean to suggest that Israel is not
a huge part of the problem um but what I
am suggesting is that Gins have two
problems and they might not you know
they're not on the same level but gazin
have an Israel problem and gazin also
have a Hamas problem they were much
safer and better off two weeks ago yeah
that's a really good way of putting it
um
I wanted to also entertain the comments
from Carl Wilson and Fanny anai that
both sort of gesture at the same thing
uh which is that a former Hamas leader
has you know publicized a sort of call
um around the globe for for Jihad
tomorrow on Friday the 13th uh and
basically put countries all around the
world on higher alert for this um do you
what do you make of this Max is this
credible is this something that people
ought to be on guard for um what do you
what do you make of this and how do
these groups typically operate is how do
we assess as lay people as as
non-experts whether these types of
things are credible or just things that
we see circulating on social
media one of the most upsetting aspects
of the October 7th attack has been the
response around the world
you know it is true I mean it's just
objectively true that hamas's
tactics in in many ways looked
absolutely as evil and barbaric as Isis
tactics um I've looked I've looked at
the pictures of I can verify them like
the the pictures of the burned babies
and going house to house and
shooting um families and this would you
would think that this might be a bridge
too far for a lot of people that even if
they support the Palestinian cause they
would be repulsed by this level of
violence you never saw big
celebrations around the world after Isis
you know burnings and shootings and
beheadings you didn't see that out of
Australia or across cities and in
America or or in Europe but you do see a
celebration of the violence of
Hamas and so Hamas is more popular even
around the world than Isis ever was and
it somehow seemed as more acceptable to
Hamas violence around the world than it
ever was to celebrate Isis
violence you know you do not have to go
far from where I live or probably from
where either of you might be to
find Gatherings of Highly
activated uh upset activists who hold
signs which in many cases are aing not
only the cause of the Palestinian
resistance but even the very disgusting
tactics against Israeli citizens on top
of that we know that according to the
latest number I saw Hamas killed
Internationals Hamas killed 22 Americans
and has an old told number of American
hostages and America is not alone these
aren't just just you know know American
Israeli citizens these are um foreigners
from from Asia for example um where they
were killed in in in numbers um and so
and again the Hamas attack is being
applauded by Al-Qaeda yeah the amount so
so when a Hamas leader in this raw
situation um is calling for
transnational
attacks outside of Israel I do take that
threat very seriously yeah the amount of
international minimizing of the
atrocities committed by Hamas and almost
celebration using the paragliders that
descended on that music festival where
260 people were killed many of whom were
teenagers and young adults uh many of
whom were tourists International um you
know foreign Nationals the celebration
of these murderous Hamas paragliders and
co-opting this image for poster art done
by black lives matter organizations in
the United States distributed on college
campuses All Over America has been so
disturbing to watch I mean I live in New
York City and watching people congregate
in Times Square and making horribly
anti-semitic comments these cheers and
jeers some of these tweets that we're
seeing and I sort of trust people to be
their worst selves on the internet but
you see many people many Ultra Ultra
online leftists academics saying things
along the lines trying to map all of
this onto this very simplistic colonizer
um oppressed narrative uh you know this
one tweet I think is so emblematic of
this mindset what did y'all think
decolonization meant Vibes papers essays
losers um and it's like well wait a
second like you could reasonably oppose
the actions of the state of Israel and
you could oppose the way that they're
leveling um so much of Gaza while still
saying that the instigating attack what
Hamas did of putting bullet holes into
children into babies uh and executing
grandmothers in front of their families
abducting people you know there there's
a little bit of misinformation sort of
floating around and it's hard to sus out
the extent to which rape was used uh
especially on some of the uh women who
were abducted from that music festival
the degree to which you know peaceful
kab
had you know all kinds of Slaughter and
and I mean these are highly trusting
communities where generally speaking
you're prepared for Air Raids but not on
the ground attacks you had you know
neighbors watching their their neighbors
and family members being murdered I just
the amount of totally ignorant if not
outright evil vitriol we are seeing
skewed from so many corners of the
American Progressive left has been
highly disturbing to watch and I do I'm
curious about whether we're seeing a
little bit of this watershed moment a
little bit of a Reckoning where there's
a sense of like well wait a second
weren't you the same people on college
campuses complaining about
microaggressions and asking to be taken
into a safe space and like how do you
think this makes Jewish students on
these University campuses feel when you
are acting like these paragliders should
be using your little canva graphic
design template I mean it's pretty
despicable to me I me also the left has
been so quick to you you know to call
everybody not
yeah you
know right and and now and now we see
the largest mass killing of Jews
literally since the Holocaust and
they're coming out and marching um for
them for on the side um of the
perpetrators uh what what typically
happens when a group uses you know
Carnage against civilians in such an
overwhelming way is it not only reduces
the likelihood of government concessions
but it does tend to um international
support but in the case of the
Palestinians um we're not seeing the
standard um International effect it's
very hard to imagine a bloodletting like
this happening somewhere else in the
world and you know so many people all
over the place in America and Europe and
Australia Etc um you know holding up
signs and saying that this is just ified
and that this this is actually good and
maybe we should see uh even more of it
um so uh that this has been you know a
secondary very disturbing aspect of the
October 7th terrorist Rampage yeah and I
think Liz is right to say that there's
the sort of simplistic oppressor
oppressed lens that so many of these
activists have been acclimated to seeing
everything through and there just this
sort of reflexive oh Palestine uh no
matter what the facts on the ground are
that's that's the side that we need to
you know align with uh before we wrap
this I say one you know just as how just
as how governments sometimes support you
know terrorist groups and they think
that it will serve them well somehow and
then it ends up sort of backfiring
against the government these problems
that we're
seeing you know who's implic in them is
actually the administrations at a lot of
these
universities where they hired
faculty um which contributed to the
radicalization um of the students and
they also built up these big Dei offices
which in frankly in many cases and this
is objectively true Based on data um
that more often than not they're
actually anti-Semitic they don't even
really view Jews as a minority group
worth
protecting um and what's happened is
we've seen a radicalization of the youth
in this country particularly at the
universities and this could get out of
control in a way that the
administrations will regret but make no
mistake it's not a coincidence that the
radicalization um is happening at a lot
of these universities and I think that
the um administrations are largely
respons for it even if they come to
regret that stance of theirs over the
last few years yeah they they created
the Frankenstein's monster and now
they're going to have to deal with it
we've kept you for a long time Max
before we we wrap up I want to ask you
one last thing which was about the role
of social media in all of this because
so many of these horrific images came
out uh I mean there the the terrorists
were taking videos posting them on
people's Facebook Facebook pages this
stuff has been all over Twitter or
x.com um and you know the light touch on
x.com has allowed a lot of this to
proliferate quite far and wide um I've
seen some of your posts about this and
you seem to lean on the side that this
should be out there as horrific as the
imagery is it it needs to be out there
could you just explain that Viewpoint
for
us
yeah the Israeli government has come out
with a statement saying that they do not
want shared um any kind of real time or
you know very recent um videos or photos
of the hostages um if they you know if
they're cases of um killings murders or
cases of torture and I and I do
understand that and I do intend on
respecting that um as a strategic matter
and and and I mean there's the issue of
identification you know you wouldn't
want to spread images which would allow
um the public to identify someone who's
suffering the worst seconds imaginable
and the worst ones of their life but as
a purely strategic matter in cases where
identification is not possible in terms
of who the hostage is
um I would recommend a different
strategy which is to actually
broadcast the horrific behavior of Hamas
I think that it if any you know it won't
convince everybody but it will convince
a lot of people um that what Hamas is
doing um is completely
unjustifiable and it provides
information which in itself is is hugely
valuable but as a strategic tool um I
also think that it could be useful to
broadcast such imagery but um I don't
intend um Ono there my final thing that
I'll say is you know there's so much
talk about social media in terms of
whether it's valuable or not and the
vast majority of it is
negative um all the stories about you
know how there's too much extremist
content there's so much disinformation
um I and there is a lot of bad stuff but
overall there's a huge net benefit um I
don't mind saying it that I'm addicted
to Twitter um I'm addicted to the news
in terms of world events um I follow it
constantly and if I didn't I'd be a lot
less informed and my voice would be much
smaller yeah I totally I totally agree I
think there's been a lot of backlash uh
to Twitter in recent uh months given the
the events the change of its ownership
but I'm there with you I'm I think that
uh it Still Remains a incredibly useful
and vibrant source of information
absolutely Max Abrams thank you so much
for talking to us where can our viewers
find your
book uh they can do it through Google um
it's on uh
Amazon um and uh
yeah it it's very rules for Rebels rules
for Rebels um right here the science of
victory in militant history and
basically it's a very ambitious book and
it looks at hundreds of militant groups
throughout world history all over the
world and basically comes up with ways
that are scientifically backed for
militant groups to maximize the chances
that they will succeed um so there's a
lot of um history in there and a lot of
social science and a lot of real world
policy implications wonderful uh and
what what is your Twitter handle in case
our viewers want to follow up with you
there thank you so much it's just my
name that's Max Abrams Max ab
ahms and uh I look forward to seeing all
of your tweets thank you go thank you so
much for speaking with reason and thank
you all for coming to watch our live
stream we'll be back again same exact
time next week uh